all right I reviewed the military movie
now let's give the hippies their shot
wanderlust
alright so wonder less stars Paul Rudd
and Jennifer Aniston they both live in
New York to both a couple and they both
lose their jobs so while they're on a
road trip to go to Paul Rudd's brother's
house they stumble across this this
hippie community pretty much and at
first I was like this is like house of
1000 corpses but like with nicer people
you know like people who were so nice
she realized wait a minute it's gonna be
like the twilight zone where it looks
like they're in heaven they're gonna be
in hell they're not in either but I'm
just saying what I thought of yes it is
a free spirit community where everyone
smokes weed and is vegan and has sex
with each other is what it is
and it makes the movie funny because
these two are so fish out of water they
like it there but they're not really
comfortable there but you know it's kind
of how you feel everyone there's just
weird to today's standards I'm just
saying then they kind of fall into it
and they start to like it although
there's this one dude who's a total
hipster douche bag at first you're like
oh the guy's alright then you're like I
can't stand this guy he's one of those
guys who takes the moral high ground
even though he's being the [ __ ] does
people just irritate the [ __ ] out of me
you know they irritate you to finally
thing is you're not really supposed to
100% like the guy you're supposed to be
like yeah you're kind of sketchy how
Paul Rudd kind of views them that's how
movies connect with their audience
filmmaking 101 here that's what you get
in this show and what is the movie for
me it was a bit yes it was funny as hell
I mean sometimes the movie got a little
annoying in your face you know like it's
almost telling you how you you're a
douche bag for you know living the way
you live and wearing a suit but all in
all everyone in this movie totally kills
it and brings their characters to life
they play their characters in the
cartoony way that their characters are
supposed to be portrayed and for that it
totally works because Paul Rudd is
perfect for this role he's in an awkward
situation he's Paul Rudd as Paul Rudd
should be which is funny because he's
now confronted with characters who are
pretty much the mirror image character
of his character in Our Idiot Brother
that is what we call Paul Rudd's range
in acting ladies and gentlemen but there
is an attractive quality to this way of
life you know you're like yeah I would
love to wake up in the morning and not
have any obligations whatsoever this
scenario is something I would not want
to do for the rest of my life but it'd
be fun to do for a couple of weeks you
know join a hippie community for like a
couple weeks and then not care about
[ __ ] and then go back to your life and
realize that you have the gravity of
responsibilities and bills on your
shoulders and you'll hate it even more
I'll stick to YouTube in the Internet
thank you in the end the movies well
acted it's funny some of the characters
and no you
they're supposed to annoy you at those
times so the movie just works I will say
wanderlust is a good time no alcohol
required in my eyes in my perspective
because that's my opinion and I can't be
wrong when it's my own opinion right
hippy movies teach me stuff however
there are a lot of dicks in this movie
and I'm not even talking about douche
Jesus over here I'm talking about the
actual dick big ones small ones old ones
creepy ones frightening ones dogs just
just it shows dog so if you're a bit on
the sensitive side you might want to
pass on wanderlust however if you can
handle it or you're a doctor or a blind
man or just someone who doesn't suffer
from old wrinkled ball sack dick a
phobia you should be fine so what are
you gonna see this weekend Act of Valor
or wonder lust whatever it may be I'll
just watch them both screen hop you know
like the hippies do I mean don't screen
up support your local movie theater or
you can stay home and watch my videos
back-to-back for hours pretty sure I
have that many videos you know it'll
it'll take up hours whatever it may be
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
you